in the Quest for groundbreaking
biomedical drug discoveries one field
has emerged as a powerful Catalyst for
Innovation chem informatics at the
Forefront of the fusion between
chemistry and informatics chem
informatics plays a pivotal role in
accelerating the discovery and
repurposing of life-changing medications
we invite you to embark on a
transformative journey through our chem
informatics for biomedical drug
Discovery program
over the years the evolution of
Technologies and cheminformatics has
revolutionized the drug Discovery
landscape by harnessing the power of
computational tools and data analysis
researchers can now navigate complex
chemical and protein databases with
unprecedented speed and accuracy
we are thrilled to launch
cheminformatics for biomedical drug
Discovery training program designed to
address the challenges associated with
understanding modeling screening and
applying cheminformatics strategies to
improve drug Discovery results
the process of finding a new drug
against a chosen Target for a particular
disease usually involves High throughput
screening where in large libraries of
chemicals are tested for their ability
to modify the target with contributions
from meeting researchers in Academia and
the biotechnology pharmaceutical
industry as well as experts from the
software industry this comprehensive
mental guided training program explains
how chem informatics enhances drug
Discovery so whether you are a beginner
eager to learn the fundamentals or an
experienced researcher looking to
enhance your skills our program caters
to all the levels of expertise all three
levels comes with different access types
now let's delve into the details of a
curriculum and explore the fascinating
topics that awaits you in the
transformative training program
in our beginner level training designed
for Learners with little to no prior
knowledge you will gain practical skills
that form the foundation of chem
informatics from exploring chemical and
protein databases to predicting protein
structures you will develop a solid
understanding of the tools and methods
used in drug Discovery you will also
gain insights into the chemical
structures and their representations
basics of drug design and optimization
exploring the exciting intersection of
machine learning algorithms and can
informatics data analysis
as you progress to our intermediate
level training your knowledge will
expand building upon a strong foundation
in molecular biology
bioinformatics and cheminformatics here
you will explore the latest advancements
in the field such as Alpha fold and
version screening for hit identification
through 12 immersive sessions you will
learn about virtual chemical screening
techniques including both ligand and
structure-based approaches gain hands-on
experience with tools like Agro slab and
protein databases moreover you will also
discover the transformative potential of
artificial intelligence in molecular
drug Discovery and its applications in
healthcare
our advanced level training is the
Pinnacle of a program intended for those
seeking to become leaders in the
pharmaceutical industry here you will
acquire a deep understanding of the
latest advances in drug Discovery and
chem informatics enabling you to
spearhead groundbreaking research
projects
over 24 sessions you will explore the
prediction of chemical activity building
machine learning model and the dynamic
landscape of pharmacology dive into the
intricate details of drug development
process and gain expertise in protein
structure prediction you will also
engage and Export discussions on cutting
HTM informatics research projects
fostering interdisciplinary approaches
to pharmacology research and development
whether you are just beginning your
journey or seeking to advance your
career in the pharmaceutical industry
are chem informatics for biomedical drug
Discovery program is your gateway to
unlocking a world of Limitless
possibilities to enroll for the program
you can visit the program page where you
will find the detailed curriculum of the
program and Associated coursework on
scrolling you'll find different levels
of enrollment options pick the one that
interests you more and meet us to get
started